Kevin Spacey releases a statement  apologizing to Anthony Rapp and coming  out as gay  spacy tweeted his statement just hours  after actor Anthony Rapp publicly  alleged Kevin Spacey made a sexual  advance towards him  when he was only 14 years old in the  statement Spacey says he is beyond  horrified does not remember the  encounter and says he owes Anthony the  sincerest apology for what would have  been deeply inappropriate drunken  behavior Spacey adds rap Story has  encouraged him to address his own  personal life quote I have had  relationships with both men and women I  have loved and had romantic encounters  with men throughout my life and I choose  now to live as a gay man I want to deal  with this honestly and openly and that  starts with examining my own behavior  [Music]